los países más poderosos del mundo
exigieron hoy a rusia respeto por la
soberanía territorial de ucrania ante la
posibilidad de una invasión hecho que
moscú ha desmentido el 17 en una
declaración conjunta también expresó su
preocupación por el aumento de las
tropas rusas en la frontera con ucrania
y advirtió que habrá graves
consecuencias en esta comunicación
oficial se lee que cualquier uso de la
fuerza para cambiar fronteras está
estrictamente prohibido por el derecho
internacional
rusia no debe tener ninguna duda de que
una mayor agresión militar contra
ucrania tendría consecuencias masivas
horas antes el g7 también instó a irán a
mantenerse en la mesa de negociación que
le permita revivir el acuerdo nuclear de
2015 negociaciones que se realizan en
viena en austria la ministra de
exteriores alemana quien ha hecho su
debut en esta cumbre de ministros de
exteriores en liverpool anna-lena barba
que dijo que el tiempo se está acabando
y que la posición actual
permite devolver las negociaciones seis
meses por ello la importancia de que se
avance este es el clamor de la comunidad
internacional prácticamente con esta
cumbre de dos días en liverpool terminan
los eventos presenciales de la
presidencia del reino unido- del g7 en
el 2022 la presidencia él asume alemania